on the theory and databases and today we
will continue with Theory and um and Ai
and I give Vandenberg and you you jump
Joy will give the four minute four
lectures peace
right uh thanks everyone for being here
um so we have four hours of material to
teach you everything we know about logic
and pro six circuits which arguably may
be less than what some of you know about
some of these topics and so you know
because it's the start of the program
please just interrupt and ask us about
something we're forgetting to mention or
I'll give you the outline soon but if we
make it through half of this I'll
already be happy we'll just find the
most interesting parts for you okay uh
so logic and probabilistic circuits so
the the main idea is that circuits
representations are somehow a nice
language to capture tractable reasoning
uh in logic and probability at the same
time and most of you are logicians so
you've probably seen circuits in that
context
um and so even though logic is Central
to this Simon's program this tutorial
will actually mostly talk about
probability
um for a few reasons one is you know we
more do probability than logic so it's
easier for us but second I think most of
the interest in the database and the AI
community in logical circuits for the
last 15 years or so has been as a means
of doing probabilistic inference as a
way to compile your probabilistic model
into some data structure logical circuit
where you can then do probabilistic
reasoning so in a sense it it you know
it matches well the actual goal that
people have
um one of the things I hope to uh
convince you of in today's tutorials is
that once you think about probability
there's very nice rich query languages
you can Define maybe that wouldn't be
natural to Define in logic and so
hopefully this will be interesting for
you to study from a algorithms point of
view or a complexity point of view and
then lastly
um you know AIS and the world is going
through a crazy time over in the age of
generative Ai and so generative AI is
all about sampling probability
distributions and so hopefully the way
that we present circuits to you today
will help you also connect things like
uh you know circuit completion
inference on circuits and circuit lower
bonds and so on to this world of
generative Ai and deep learning okay
um
I do recognize that we're not really
here to talk about machine learning so I
will spare you most of the machine
learning details except where I maybe
connect to some kind of machine learning
models deep learning architectures and
we'll mostly talk about representations
query languages reasoning algorithms and
some connections to Theory to uh um to
generating polynomials to Circuit lower
bounds and so on okay
all right so this is on the menu for
today uh I will start giving you a very
gentle introduction hopefully to the
world of probabilistic models in Ai and
machine learning uh and I'll try to uh
Define what are some interesting
probabilistic queries you may want to
compute on these models
um and we'll discuss for most of the
popular ones whether they're tractable
models or whether they're intractable
for computing Computing these types of
queries
um and then second I'll talk about promo
stick circuits which is this convenient
framework this kind of circuit language
framework where it's pretty easy to
analyze for different query languages
whether they are efficient to compute or
not and so this will hopefully connect
to your knowledge of attractability and
logic and so on
and so then ujunk takes over and she'll
tell you about you know what is the
connection to logical circuits binary
decision diagrams sdds ddnnfs all of
those kind of classic logical
representations and show that you know
they are really very much the same thing
in a way and most of the probabilistic
models we use are actually inspired in
very direct Ways by what people have
done in the logic circuit world
the new Jung will tell you how do you
take your favorite other model and
compile it into a circuit
we'll talk about the circuit size lower
bounds tractability uh how it relates to
Circuit size and so on and then Eugene
will try to impress you by giving you
some query languages that you would
imagine could never be computed
efficiently and then still show you that
they can be computed efficiently if you
have the right model the right circuit
language
and so this will hopefully be exciting
for you know database folks who love
query languages that get us as fancy as
they get right
okay so then I take over again and uh so
this will be later in the afternoon and
I'm very eager to tell you uh or to
discuss this question are all tractable
distributions uh actually circuits is
this somehow a universal language for
all things that can be efficiently
computed and um so I would like to give
you some interesting recent results in
that direction
and then finally what I I hope will
won't have time for is to actually tell
you how the machine learning side of all
of this works how you train these things
on the GPU from massive amounts of data
because I don't think anyone here is
particularly interested in that topic
but I could cover it if you're curious
or I can give you the high level story
okay
um and again you know if we you know
just tell me what you care about and or
even if it's not on this slide and I
will hopefully tell you right so let's
let's make this interactive I will force
then to ask some questions later okay I
should acknowledge that the slides we
use are based on tutorials and slides
from other people so thanks to all these
folks for all the hard work they did
um and so let's get started so here we
see some alphabet super probabilistic
models in AI uh you can make a similar
slide for logical representations in Ai
and so here there's a bunch of things
that look familiar things like the naive
base distribution you've probably seen
at some point
um tree shaped graphical models on the
on the side here is GPT Transformers
right chat GPT gpt4 Etc there are some
really famous models like variational
Auto encoders uh generative adversarial
networks are somewhere in this soup and
so these are all probabilistic models
that Define somehow a distribution or a
way to sample new things from the world
okay and it's a bit confusing to make
sense of this soup
and so the way that we will
put some structure here is to say that a
bunch of them are tractable uh the ones
over there these are ones where there
are certain query classes that I can
compute efficiently on this
representation
and then there's a bunch of other things
that are intractable where you know they
really don't allow you to compute things
exactly and efficiently uh on on the you
know even though they represent the
distribution
but of course it's a little bit more
subtle than that it's not just tractable
versus intractable we'll talk about the
spectrum of tractability where depending
on the query language you have
you might have a tractable models some
models are tractable for almost any
question you ask some models are
tractable for nothing and some are
trackable for only a few types of query
classes you might have and I'll try to
make this concrete soon
okay then there's a second orthogonal
dimension which is also really important
which is how expressive are these models
and so we know that for example a
Transformers is very very expressive it
can somehow capture all text on the
internet and all all human language
Behavior quite well on the other hand
the naive based model is very naive it's
so naive that they had to put it in the
name just to you know make it clear and
so what we would like of course is we
would like an expressive model
especially among the ones that are
tractable that can still represent very
very complex distributions while still
being tractable
okay and then the final takeaway that
we'll get to in my parts the first two
halves are the first two parts of this
tutorial is
um you know how do we make sense of this
alphabet soup I don't really want to
explain to you all of these different
models it turns out that they're really
almost all the same thing
um you can really think of them as just
circuits in some syntax and they all
have similar properties and you know
I'll try to just give you the essence of
these things and once you know you know
this framework of pro six circuits all
of these things are really just
different Syntax for the same kind of
model so hopefully you will understand
all of this without having to study them
individually
okay any questions at this point
oh
so let's get started with tractable
inference query classes and so on um and
so you know this is a type of slide that
I mostly use to explain uh when I teach
this to machine Learners what is a query
right because people people don't
actually know what a query is in for
example in machine learning
um but for you this is very natural but
okay let's let's indulge anyway and talk
about queries what are queries
um so here's a query that I might ask
what's the probability that today is a
Monday and there's a traffic jam on
Westwood Boulevard so you know we're
going to translate these intuitive
queries to random variables so there's a
distribution here over the the day of
the week the time whether it's a traffic
jam in all the streets of Los Angeles
and so this query here specifically is
asking in my distribution over however
the traffic in Los Angeles behaves
what's the probability that it's a
Monday and there's a traffic jam on
Westwood Boulevard okay so this is what
you would call a marginal query and this
will be the almost simplest type of
query that we're going to consider today
there will be many many more many much
more complicated ones
um
okay
um here's another query which day is
most likely to have a traffic jam on my
route to campus
so again we assume that our model is the
same probability distribution over these
random variables and now we would like
to ask what's the the day that most
likely uh has a traffic jam in any one
of these streets that are on my route to
campus okay so this is a little bit more
complicated it uses some features of the
query language like map inference what's
the most likely day it uses some event
that is not just
there is a traffic jam on Westwood
Boulevard but some logical event
something that you specify as a as a
sentence in logic and it also of course
uses marginalization because it doesn't
really talk about the other streets and
so on and so on okay so this will be a
bit more complicated and so Eugene will
tell you how to deal with these types of
more advanced queries
okay so what do we mean when we say
tractable and this
hopefully is kind of intuitive for you
right so you've probably already figured
this out so a class of queries is
trackable on some family of models if uh
essentially the query any query in this
class runs in time polynomial in the
size of the model and so size of the
model is of course a bit arbitrarily
defined but because we'll be dealing
with circuits this will always be the
number of edges in the circuits okay
um
and for almost all of the query classes
we'll talk about a polynomial will
actually be linear which is very
important if you want to make this
practical and actually plug this into
some machine learning Pipeline and so on
right so we're not going to do things
that are you know size of M to the power
1000 it's going to be a linear in the
size of the circuit
it has to be clear the way you stated
the program could be combined complexity
or data complexity but you actually get
in mind data complex for every fixed
query yeah so from a database
perspective the model the model is the
database I guess and then this is data
complexity yes thank you typically the
queries so it gets more complicated when
the query becomes let's say a logical
event which also has a very rich
structure then you want to be polynomial
about in the size of your probabilistic
model and the size of your query written
as a logical sentence so that's a more
advanced definition and so your general
get into those types of queries but for
now the queries will be very simple
there's nothing interesting in their
structure
okay
um so let's do this exercise where we
figure out for a bunch of models and a
bunch of query classes whether they're
tractable and let's start with a very
very simplest one so here is a query
Yeah question
can you will you define what is a
probabilistic model to any joint
probability distribution over these
random variables so beta Network
whatever like variational autoencoder a
Transformer GPT
any joint distribution over these random
variables yeah so we'll look at some
specific representations in just a
second
okay
uh here's our very very simplest query
complete evidence or likelihoods so this
is asking what's the probability that
today's a Monday it's exactly 12 there's
a traffic jam on Westwood Boulevard and
nowhere else so basically you fix all of
the random variables values you leave
nothing unknown and now you want to
compute this probability okay so the the
reason why we care about this type of
query is because this is very
fundamental and maximum likelihood
learning when we're given data
whatever text from the internet images
we do have a value for every pixel we do
know which token is is every sentence is
in every sentence so when we train these
models we want to be able to compute
queries in this class and then maximize
the likelihood meaning find those
parameters that make this number higher
okay
um it's not really a type of query that
you would as a user necessarily want to
ask except when you're maybe doing
things like outlier detection but it's
very important as part of the learning
Loop okay
um so let's take our favorite uh
generative model from uh five years ago
the generative adversarial Network right
so I don't know how many tens of
thousands of papers have been written
about this specific uh representation of
a probability distribution I'll spare
you the machine learning details
you can ask if you really care but
essentially what this is doing is it's
defining some way of first generating
let's say fake images and then training
a model to detect which ones are fake
and which ones are real and then somehow
having them compete so that you start
generating images that are more and more
realistic so this model doesn't have an
explicit likelihood it's it's being
trained in this way where you have these
two neural networks kind of trying to
beat each other at some game
um and so there's no way to actually
compute the likelihood you cannot ask
these models what's the probability of
this specific image there's no way to do
that
um there's reasons why people care or
don't care about these architectures but
bottom line is so this is already a
model class that is intractable for even
the simplest query which is the
likelihood all right so this was a
little warm-up exercise so let's look at
the second favorite
deep learning model for probability
distributions the variational auto
encoder this one I find a bit more
interesting it's a latent variable model
it's saying that there's some kind of
embedding space where we have a
distribution and if you take some
embedding you can decode it into an
image let's say and then there's a
clever way to actually get a posterior
on Z and so on and so on
um but all of this Machinery which I
suppose you don't care about so I don't
have to tell you this is also kind of
using approximations lower bounds to
estimate what roughly would be the
likelihood of a particular image so
likelihood of the model for a particular
image and so again Computing this is
intractable and it's also something that
does not support this class of queries
the structure of how to represents
something yeah so that's somehow hidden
in here if you want to compute the
probability of an image you have to
essentially integrate over all possible
continuous vectors that could possibly
you know every single Vector could
possibly generate every possible image
so you have to kind of do this
integration where we say you know for a
given image what's the probability of
every single infinitely many
accountability many embedding to
generate it that integral is just
completely interactive anything is
connected everything you can't exploit
some structures and personal structure
whatsoever yeah
yeah exactly so I won't really talk
about it too much more I'm just trying
to dismiss these models that's not
really interesting for the purpose of
querying uh as like a database person
should we understand this as there is a
proof of intractability or we just don't
know how to do it it's very easy to
prove I'll do it in the brick
yeah it's very simple because even even
just let's say that this was a uniform
distribution this was just a sigmoid
it's already
very easy okay
um all right so let's look at our next
machine learning model so here it says
normalizing flows these are very popular
with machine Learners you've probably
never heard of them
um so they are kind of telling us that
uh what we really need is a distribution
over some Z variable that we don't know
some latent variable and then for every
Z we will map it to an X using a
bijection
and because we have a bijection there's
actually this change of volume term here
we can actually compute for a particular
image you know if we invert this
function what's the probability of Z and
then also how much does our function
actually blow up or Shrink the volume in
this particular area of the space
don't worry about it it's a bunch of
machine learning stuff but you know it
kind of explains why a lot of neural
networks are actually able to compute
the likelihoods okay so these are models
where we can compute and need the
probability of a specific image so
that's something okay we have finally a
model that's tractable for a particular
query
um all right so that's success so let's
make the problem harder okay
uh so let's look at these marginal
queries that I mentioned a while ago so
marginal query looks like this it's kind
of like this probability this this evi
this likelihood query where we deleted a
bunch of information so now we have to
reason about whatever values could be
there
okay so this is what it looks like and
you can think of these of course as just
integrating out all of the the hidden or
the latent variables from this
distribution
um where all of the Hidden variables are
just all the variables that are not
observed which are the X variables okay
I hope this makes sense
and a very related problem is Computing
conditional probabilities because if you
can compute a marginal probability you
can also compute a conditional
probability as we all know
all right this is quite useful as a
problem so throughout the tutorial we'll
have a few pointers to like application
slides that tell you this is useful in
robotics or computer vision and so on so
you can be motivated as you prove your
theorems that you know people might you
know like like to use your theorem in
some application
um so let's go back to our normalizing
flow so we kind of like them because we
we can compute the probability of a
complete image a complete feature Vector
but unfortunately Computing marginals is
again intractable now we have to compute
some integral
over this thing and you know unless this
function is super super trivial this is
very easy to prove also to be
intractable okay
um so if I have a normalizing flow model
and I have an image where I maybe don't
observe the the the right half of the
image I would never know how likely the
left half is of the image it's
impossible
all right
um so flow's a little bit tractable but
not really
okay so let's go back in our time
machine before the Deep learning
Revolution and let's look at graphical
models things like Bayesian networks
question so
um so when he went here we talk about
the black ability you mean exact
computation
or yeah
a lot of sense to have an approximation
right I'll talk about it in two slides
and then let's see if you're happy with
the answer yeah and we'll talk a little
bit later about sampling yeah
but feel free to ask later if I don't
address your question
um
yeah
that's true
they're very often used because all of
them really like to sample new images
which is kind of what we're all doing
now we're kind of pretending that just
generating more images is like solving
everything
uh and it's it's interesting right but
yeah so we'll talk later about
if you are able to compute tractively
things like marginals what more can you
do with this so hopefully that will also
become clear later it's like what's the
point of wanting to do more why do we
even care about these queries
so again hopefully soon you will be
given the answer so I guess that all the
models that you're describing are
trackable to sample yes that's the base
Point sampling is trackable on all of
these correct okay great questions I
like to get the signal that you're
following along
um okay back in the time machine back to
graphical models
um so I guess many of you are familiar
we have nodes that represent random
variables these edges represent
dependencies in the distribution and
there's a lot of classic algorithms you
know based on recursive conditioning
variable elimination message passing
that will compute for you the
probability of some marginal uh in these
types of models so this has been studied
very extensively
um but unfortunately it's also not
tractable right it's well known that
Computing a marginal probability on the
Bayesian Network is a Sharpie hard right
so that's a very kind of classic result
and then already maybe it's your
question
approximating a marginal or a
conditional is also hard right so within
a relative error of 2 to the N to the
and one minus Epsilon for any fixed
epsilence and P hard uh and so what
we're really using these models for when
we're sampling is we're just hoping that
somehow they are they are well behaved
by accident and on average they get us
something reasonable and very many
applications that use sampling or
message passing they really just hope
that you know giving some answers better
than giving no answer and you know it
you can build something around it but
there's really no guarantee whatsoever
that the numbers you get out of these
algorithms at all correspond to the
truth
sorry this was so this was marginals and
this was conditional probability uh I I
very quickly skipped over this
conditional queries here yeah sorry
um other questions
so yeah approximations are not
necessarily quickly giving us a solution
here when we have these intractable
models
um but of course I think you all know
about tree wits right how tree-like is
this graphical model and so tree which
is of course is this parameter that if
we uh you know fix it then we can
actually compute marginals efficiently
and it's a fixed parameter tractable
entry with so a very natural thing to do
and I guess this community kind of knows
this right I don't really have to go
into this but
um what's very natural to do is to say
that well instead of considering all
graphical models let's just only deal
with ones that have small tree width so
then we have a distribution on which we
can really query whatever we want and
that's turning out to be a very fruitful
idea especially in things like
computational biology for genomic
sequences and so on
um but also in just machine learning
where there's plenty of proposals of you
know let's look at the data and let's
extract from the data something like
politry at injunction tree and so on
just you know learn a distribution that
that has by Design low treatments
um and so in practice that means that
you know treatment can be up to 20 and
it runs and higher than that it won't
run and you know it kind of works it's a
tractable model okay
um so tree distribution slightly more in
detail looks like this it's essentially
a Bayesian Network where every variable
has exactly one parent
so it factorizes in this particular way
as a product of variables given their
parent
um and everything runs in time linear in
the number of random variables um and
what's really neat is even if you want
to learn these models from data you want
to compute the maximum likelihood a tree
shaped graphical model given some data
the classic charleutri algorithm which
is ancient
we'll actually do this also efficiently
for you okay so it's a very beautiful
class of distributions and it's
tractable for all of these things
is about a knife base a particular case
of a tree distribution yes yeah so a
naive base every variable has one parent
or zero yeah
um yeah but it yeah exactly
uh
three algorithm is finding a Maxwell
spanning tree in the mutual information
graph
uh of the data
between variables and this is probably
giving you the optimal appreciate
graphical model
yeah so it's different from yanakakis
which I guess is the the database
equivalent of the variable elimination
algorithm for graphical models
so there's an issue though
we actually lost something all of these
models we had previously they can they
can capture distributions over images of
cats and dogs that are very complicated
they can even capture distributions over
natural language
but our tree shaped graphical model has
a much harder time with this
because we kind of restricted the
dependencies to be only from one
variable to the next everything has one
parent we somehow lose the ability to
represent all the distributions we no
longer have a class of models that can
do uh can represent everything
but there's also a solution for this
problem uh in AI machine learning which
is just build mixtures if you build
mixtures of things you can fit anything
okay
um so let's take for example two
gaussians and create a mixture of two
gaussians it looks like this right some
complex combinations of simpler
distributions and you know we can still
compute our likelihood marginals
conditional probabilities we just have
to do so in every single component of
our mixture and then kind of average the
result
so this is a nice cheap way of getting
uh good results and will actually
heavily use this idea when we build Pro
listing circuits it's very convenient to
actually think of these mixture models
as actually having a hidden variable z a
latent variable that tells you which of
the two components we are drawing a
sample from okay so when you get a
mixture of two gaussians implicitly in
there is some categorical random
variable that tells you which of the
gaussians does my data come from
okay that's really just capturing this
weight here all right this is kind of
choosing it's flipping a coin and
choosing which of my gaussians am I
going to get my data from
and so we'll later on actually use the
fact that you know you can make explicit
to these latent variables and they will
tell us something about query
tractability later
okay so we have increased expressiveness
but uh unfortunately uh well you can
prove that in the limits of infinitely
many components in your mixture you can
do whatever you want so that's nice okay
it's it's fully expressive
um
but what we really care about is not
expressiveness we don't really care you
know with infinitely many parameters can
we fit this data the question is with
some finite amount of you know it could
be millions or billions but it's still a
finite number of parameters can we
actually fit all text on the internet
okay
um and so that's a different story so
that's not really a story of
expressiveness but what machine Learners
would call perhaps expressive efficiency
and what logicians would perhaps call
succinctness so this is the question of
uh how compactly can we represent
complicated distributions okay and so
here I would like to intuitively argue
that you know even though a mixture of
gaussians is very expressive in the
limits it's perfectly expressive in the
finite it's kind of a useless thing for
example let's say we want to have a
mixture of gaussians that represents any
of these four different distributions
then this is what we get if we have a
mixture of two gaussians it doesn't
really look great right this is these
are the two guys questions I think here
we have maybe 10 gaussians
not really a very good approximation
here I think we have a hundred gaussians
and here it starts to look okay but but
barely right and so the problem here is
you just need a massive massive number
of components in your mixture to
actually have this expressiveness in
practice it's not very expressive
efficient
okay yeah but classical machine learning
theory will tell you that you don't want
to fit every piece of text in the
internet right yeah what is the
trade-off between regularization and
expressiveness here that's a very good
question uh which I was not planning to
get into which is a very end of the
tutorial
um but yeah so having
the capacity somewhat limited actually
does help you be more robust sometimes
intuitively
um and um the reason why in practice
even when you learn like a mixture of
100 gaussians from data it doesn't work
it's just because actually optimizing
this marginal likelihood landscape is
impossible it's
highly multimodal and
so so even though in theory yeah so so
this also doesn't work and then okay
even though this is a good regularizer
it's probably not good enough to capture
all Politics on the internet so you kind
of lose either way that's the short
answer
okay
yes so getting back to the theory what
if I think about a finite distribution
uh
binary how many mixtures of uh I know
three like major networks do I need to
represent an arbitrary distribution uh
that's a good question my guess would be
if you have any random variables two to
the two to the N minus one yeah I I
don't I think so because you can always
construct well okay someone probably
proved this over the lunch break Not Me
Maybe you can but you can probably
construct the probability table where
the numbers are somehow different enough
that they can not be generated by convex
combinations of things and whatever so I
think you'll solve that problem very
quickly yeah okay
um good question so yeah maybe there's a
problem in here to work studying uh okay
so mixtures are tractable but we have
this caveats okay
um let's make the problem even harder I
would like to know which combination of
Roads is most likely to be jammed on
Monday at 9am
uh so here we have something called uh
map inference
um we have some observed values for our
random variables we have a question of
what is the most likely state of all the
other random variables okay all of the
other ones
um this is also an interesting query
class and we'll talk about it later as
we find a model for you know that is
tractable for this query class
um yeah this is just writing the same
thing right we have query and evidence
and together they they form the set of
all random variables
um
okay so unfortunately uh even if we have
a mixture of gaussians or let's say a
knight base classifier where the the
class is a latent variable or any kind
of mixture of trees
Computing this is uh also intractable
the reason is that these mixture models
implicitly they have this hidden
variable Z that tells us which of the
components of the mixture am I actually
drawing from and implicitly we're
actually marginalizing out that variable
and so the max of the sum is not the
same as the sum of the Max and so we
cannot really
solve this maximization problem in each
of the components separately and then
somehow aggregate the result because
that's not correct okay
uh and so now we have a slightly harder
query
um which is intractable for even mixture
models
um
again if you want to look at
applications here's a slide where you
can find some fun things to do with map
inference specifically you can find the
most likely completion of an image that
you only partially observe that's a fun
thing to do
uh all right so for map inference
um all of these things were already
intractable for mixtures you cannot do
it because it's this latent variable you
cannot really deal with on a tree shaped
graphical model you can still compute
your map inference
um so we're pushing the picture forward
and we're seeing that there's actually
quite quite some interesting properties
here
okay let's make the problem harder
let's say I want to know which
combination of Roads is most likely to
be jammed at 9am regardless of the day
okay
I don't really care about Monday
specifically
so now we have almost the same query
except
I'm implicitly summing over all days of
the week I don't really care which day
of the week it is so now we again have
this problem where we have the max of
the sun which is not the same as the sum
of a Max and we cannot possibly compute
this and it's uh you know you can prove
that this is intractable and folks have
done so so on a general graphical model
this is NP to the pp complete even on a
tree this is NP heart even on live base
this is NP Hearts okay uh just
marginalizing out a few variables
make sense
meditation
um
it's been a while since I read these
papers but there's some kind of subset
sunlight problem that you can
solve here
I forgot the details do you remember
anything
or maybe Dennis remembers
[Music]
yeah
we can look it up for you the bunch
there's also here okay marginal Maps
very difficult even though it's in
English it looks like a very natural
type of query task in your distribution
all right so this is the picture uh
nothing's tractable right here
and there are actually many more query
classes that we'll consider today
um
so we already talked about this one
which is way more complicated than what
we already discussed right it's somehow
the combination of this map inference
finding the most likely value with
marginalization over events that are
defined in logic so Eugene will talk
about those types of queries
um
you can have query classes that ask you
know is it are there more traffic jams
in Westwood than Hollywood like
essentially looking at accounts among
sets of random variables so this is kind
of like comparing aggregate queries or I
don't know how you want to think of this
so we'll talk about
languages that can solve these types of
queries is traffic more uncertain on
weekdays so Eugene will spend quite a
lot of time talking about information
theoretic queries Computing things like
entropy scale divergences between
distributions efficiently in time linear
in the size of the the distributions
representation
and the new Jungle also talk about uh
for example this type of question what's
the causal effect of doing roadworks uh
causal backdoor estimation causal effect
estimation where we also are given a
distribution plus some causal
assumptions about what causes what and
then you want to know what's the effect
of a certain operation if I do it on my
distribution okay and so these are all
way more complicated than anything I
already showed you and so we'll cover
hopefully all that ground
uh there's one distribution however
that is tractable for anything you could
possibly want to do
uh any advanced query marginal map
whatever
there's one distribution that's always
tractable and it's this one it's a fully
factorized model
so if I have a graphical model where
nothing depends on anything
I just have a product of univariate
simple distributions then I can compute
whatever I want I can compute evidence
marginal map and so on
but obviously
this is a dumb thing to do because this
is not the real world in the real world
things depend on each other however
I'm not showing you this slide to be
annoying the idea of representing
distributions through factorization will
actually also be a key ingredient in the
more advanced models we talk about later
so the idea is important this particular
implementation is ridiculously dumb and
you would never want to do it but it
does give you tractability
okay
um all right
okay so overview of this part of the the
talk we have these two Dimensions we
have things that are very expressive
efficient and not very expressive
efficient we have things that are very
tractable it's very intractable and
hopefully I convinced you that most of
the popular kind of deep learning ways
of representing a distribution are very
expressive
you know the internet can be captured
but not much you can do with them
usually you can just sample sometimes
you can compute a likelihoods okay
on the other hand we have our favorite
classical AI things things like naive
base fully factorized distribution to
reshape graphical models simple mixtures
of gaussians they are very inexpressive
but very tractable and of course why we
want to be is somewhere here in this
sweet spot in the top right corner and
so that will be the the topic of the the
next part
all right have I answered these
questions for you what are probabilistic
queries and are the current worlds
collectible so I hope I did so and um
for the next 20 minutes
22 minutes yeah so by the way I should
mention we haven't really partitioned
these eight questions into like perfect
you know four times one hour slots so we
will try to take a break
possibly in the middle of a story but
hopefully you'll be then enticed to come
back for the second
for the next part okay
so hopefully you're convinced about this
first bullet point here so let's now
talk about probabilistic circuits and
why they are trackable for these queries
all right so the goal here is to give uh
given some class of queries or reasoning
tasks can we design some expressive
models that are tractable for it and
because you know we're in the age of
deep learning we would like these to be
somehow similar to your neural networks
we want them to be computation graphs
that are deep and expressive okay
um
already showed you this and so these
circuits that we'll talk about they will
kind of live in this corner
and there's kind of two ways to achieve
this one is to start simple
stick pick your tractable model that's
very inexpressive and try to somehow
over parameterize it try to have you
know give it you know 500 million
parameters and then hope that it becomes
rich enough to capture interesting
things
so that's one way to go and in some
sense that's kind of what we're doing
but in another sense what we're going to
do is also just take these deep learning
models and impose some structure on them
structure that allows us to compute
things efficiently
all right so let's start simple
um so we're going to build computation
graphs and the base case of a circuit or
a computation graph is an input
distribution okay and so here we'll uh
treat we'll consider some arbitrary set
of inputs like gaussians for example
um and we can also consider things like
um indicator variables right if you're a
logician you can think of this as being
a very simple distribution it gives 100
probability to X being false okay
um so you know if you're a logician
please just think of these as you know
literals
and we will assume that we can do a few
things with these very base case
elements we'll assume that whatever
query we're interested in you can always
compute it on these uh Atomic forms
right uh we can ask a gaussian what's
the what's the probability density of
1.3 it happens to be this probability
density we can ask it what's the
marginal which if you have a single
random variable is basically asking to
give us one which is the normalized
distribution sum overall you know
probabilities or if you want to deal
with unnormalized distributions this
would be called the partition function
don't worry about it you can ask
gaussian give us your most likely State
give us the mode of this distribution so
all of these basic things we assume we
can ask okay
of course we can also ask these of a
logical literal these are also easy to
to ask there
okay so now we have things like
gaussians or literals and we need to
somehow combine them into a more
complicated computation graph
and we already know how to do that to
take something that's inexpressive and
make it more expressive which is the
idea of mixture models
um and so here we have a gaussian
mixture model that I showed you earlier
and we will now just represent exactly
the same thing as a circuit so there
will be some variable X1 which is the
input to our circuit uh we give it to
the first gaussian and the second
gaussian and then we kind of mix the
result together
okay and now if I want to compute
something like the the probability of a
particular value
um I I say what's the the probability
density of five in my mixture of
gaussians first component says 0.06
second one says 0.21 we create a mixture
of them so we average these out and we
get a for the mixture of gaussians a
likelihood density of 0.09 okay so it's
just a simple feed forward computation
that gets us the probability of a of a
particular value
um for the rest of the tutorial I'm
going to skip kind of this part here I'm
just going to give you these base case
distributions and all of them will be
annotated with some scope which is which
random variable are we talking about so
both of these costumes are talking about
random variable X1 all right so
hopefully that notation won't be too
confusing and I won't really put these
arrows everywhere so these are circuits
that kind of do the feed forward
computation in a natural way
all right so now we have mixtures of
gaussians but we we only have a single
random variable
ideally we would like to have a very
high dimensional distribution meaning
one over many thousands of random
variables so how do we take a
distribution over one variable and make
it a distribution over two variables
well we we multiply the distributions we
do this ideal factorization which was
the ridiculous thing I showed you
earlier but it does allow you to expand
the scope of your distribution to
multiple random variables okay and so
here for example we could have a joint
distribution over three random variables
that is the product of independent
gaussians and so this is kind of like a
diagonal covariance matrix
multi-dimensional gaussian okay a very
simple idea but it does give us some
extra power and will of course represent
this operation of factorization using a
product node and so this is now our
little product of uh three uh three
um
essentially three-dimensional gaussian
okay yeah it's black it's there's no
covariance
yeah yeah so this basically means
there's Independence between the three
random variables
very simple
multivariant Gauss okay
again if I'm given some data points
where I know the value of X1 X2 and X3 I
can ask each of these gaussians How
likely are these values and I can
multiply them to get the likelihood
under this factorized model it should be
pretty straightforward all right
and now we just have to make a little
bit of an inductive leap where we say
let's just do this recursively
right we have our input distributions
gaussians we have our mixtures of things
we have our factorizations of things and
now we just built you know mixtures of
factorizations of mixtures of
factorizations and we end up with a
circuit language that looks like this
okay
that makes sense for you I mean this is
a natural thing for most people here I
guess
um all right so this is nice uh and you
can also do this in code if you like to
just program things instead of proof
theorems you can play with actually
building these things yeah
so if you happen to define a language
over
yeah so depending on which framework you
use the representation of this circuit
will be different I think here it's
really just
like okay on the CPU just a pointers so
the GPU end up with some kind of sparse
Matrix format which which is when you
get interested of course where you would
yeah essentially so what we tend to do
is actually layer the circuits have like
a different Matrix for every layer so we
can on the GPU easily compute queries
but there's there's a few design choices
you can make yeah
represents like a circus with like 500
million edges it's like a long trivial
systems engineering
can you go back one slide yes so I'm
trying to understand here the the
conceptual framework so if I look at the
variables x 1 x 2 x 3 and 4 and so and
so on
you started with somebody as being
independent random variables right so
here they're independent no but they're
right at the end there are India
independent
um
X1 is in this circuit no so nothing is
independent of anything because as soon
as you create a mixture of two things
even though variables are independent in
the components they're no longer
independent in the mixture
that's intuitive to see but yeah mixture
is basically break all independencies
that could exist in their components but
but you start with the independent
distributions yes yeah so every product
here is expressing some Independence
between the inputs but it immediately
gets broken by the mixture you put on
top of it
I see so you're you're adding two
distributions uh there might have been
independent but once you add them they
are okay I mean maybe I can make this
more intuitive for you by saying let's
let's consider a naive based model right
so in naive days given the class
variable The Roots all of the features
the leaves are independent okay but in
the joint distribution where you
marginalize over all classes the
features are not independent because
some features tend to co-occur more
often in certain classes right and so
that's how the dependency comes into the
culture thank you I think I
to query evaluation policies where the
input
then but once you do the query if you
look at the result yeah you get all
these mixtures right yeah given the
query the tuples are no longer
independent
okay
great question yeah
technically this is
like yes so you don't have to create a
local variable for some of these
circuits to reuse them yeah and this
happens to be just one DSL there's a few
others okay
foreign
um that's a good question uh at some
point we were doing some research on
exactly this can we somehow generalize
the independent
and still be tractable and we found a
way to do it I would have to check my
notes to recall how it works but then we
couldn't really get the model to train
in a way where we could convince machine
Learners that the edit expressiveness
actually helps you to put data better so
I think that the project can start but
we should revisit since if you're
interested yeah
okay
all right can you make a can you make a
historical note here to say like how
long ago have this some product networks
become quite interesting yeah so in the
afternoon I have a bunch of slides kind
of connecting you know what is actually
this alphabet suit and what's in it
right
um arguably all of the classical
graphical models that do some product
inference like hidden Market models
child increase they're all instances of
this and we'll talk about that later
so in that case it goes back to 1968 or
even earlier
um the graph representation I would say
mostly so people I think we're doing PDD
based probabilistic inference in the
late 90s but mostly with arithmetic
circuits in 99 this kind of circuit
representation was I guess popularized
most and at the same time there were
things like N4 graphs are in a vectors
Group which are also a form of circuits
in a different syntax
um so there's been a lot of work uh
Mantra Diego International decision
graphs in 2005.
Pedro Domingos introduced some product
networks in 2011 so there have been lots
of alphabets to acronyms that kind of
all are the same rough uh kind of
circuit-based ballistic model idea
happy to mention others if you yeah
let's go to the previous slide
so my understanding of circus is that
these
will provide the input and then you do
some computations through this
but I mean
you have the same variable labels yeah
how is it possible that we have two
random variables with the same name
that's your question yeah exactly yeah
very good yeah so uh the simplest case
is to look at here why do we have two
random variables X1 because we have a
mixture of two gaussians and both of
these gaussians are talking about the
same random variables yeah but it's
counterintuitive if you see it as a
graph like why are two of the inputs the
same they're essentially two different
base distributions on the same random
variable that you mix together somehow
yeah
good so um
the of a specific feature Vector then we
ask all of the little gaussians in this
probabilistic circuit what's the
probability density of these values they
all have their own opinion about what
that should be and specifically even if
you have X4 the same random variable
these two different gaussians will have
two different probability densities for
for that random variable
then we just have factorizations of
mixtures recursively so we take sums of
products of sums of products and we end
up with in this entire very complex
distribution a density of 0.75 so the
probability of a complete data point is
just this feed forward evaluation okay
should be straightforward hopefully
we're going to make this much more
complicated
all right so is this it we just take
sums of products of sums of products and
we have essentially a neural network
with many layers and that's it uh no
it's a little bit more complicated
um we'll actually have to study certain
properties of this structure in order to
compute anything that's more complicated
than just a likelihood okay and so
that's the next part but I feel like
maybe
we should leave that for uh after the
break you still have seven minutes
[Applause]
so much Authority that I feel like I
cannot I cannot all right so I'll really
introduce as much as I can
um
and I do so poorly because I'm tired
after an hour
um the first property we care about is a
decomposability and I'll just spend
seven minutes talking about
decomposability now um
so the idea is that in a factorization
you're not really to you're not really
allowed to multiply some probability of
the the height of a person
with the probability of the heights of a
person like you need to multiply things
that are different random variables
otherwise it doesn't make sense you
don't want to get probability Square in
your units okay so that's essentially
the idea of decomposability is whenever
we have a factorization the random
variables have to be different from each
other
okay so if you think of it as a
factorization this is a super intuitive
concept
um I will get to this later but uh
Theory people may recognize this as a
syntactic multilinearity is anyone
nodding syntactic multilinearity is what
sir
yeah
what do you mean
uh that's not what I mean but that's
also related yeah okay
oh excuse me within each product there's
only one yeah every local note has the
fact that what it's multiplying does not
share any variables so so I think in in
arithmetic circuit lower bounds you
would call the syntactic multilinearity
as far as I know
um okay this is a non-decomposable
circuit you're multiplying two gaussians
that both talk about the same random
variable doesn't make sense it's not a
lot okay second property
smoothness is also super intuitive if
you think of uh sums as being mixtures
then this is saying when I build a
mixture of two gaussians I always mix
together the same random variable right
I want to have a more complicated
distribution over let's say the age of
people in Berkeley I'm not allowed to
create a mixture between the age of
people in Berkeley and the temperature
of the Sun like those are different
things you cannot mix them together in
one distribution and so that's really
just what smoothness says mixtures are
always over identically scoped
distributions
this is a non-smooth circuit where
somehow we violate this constraint
um so decomposability is an interesting
property because getting decomposability
in your circuit is a somewhat
non-trivial thing if you start from some
other representation like getting
decomposability is a hard problem
smoothness is very easy if you give me a
circuit that's not smooth I can always
make it smooth by just adding a few
extra dummy random variables so this is
kind of a boring property but we'll
assume it because it makes all the
algorithms easier what does it mean what
is a nonsense
um I mean you could still somehow say
that whatever variable is not being used
is somehow not part of the likelihood
computation and it's still defines
somehow a distribution it just doesn't
really make sense because it's kind of
leaving some it's multiplying by by one
which is an unnormalized distribution
you can give it semantics but it's not
pretty so let's not go there so I guess
a semantics is part of how you enforce
it can you maybe is it easy to explain
how to enforce smoothness on this yes so
if I want smoothness here I would
basically add a multiplication with a
sum note of that basically gives a
uniform distribution over x1's values
here's some so I'm basically saying
implicitly if I'm missing a variable
here in the mixture it means that I'm
multiplying by one which is the low up
and so multiplying by one means that for
this variable I have a uniform
distribution moreover one that's
unnormalized that's just one everywhere
that's how smoothing works if you want
if you want to give semantics to this
thing that's how smoothing works
on the weights
um yes so these you would still multiply
whatever variable is missing here the
one will still be multiplied by the same
W1 yeah but it is two copies
no because these are different gaussians
so different means and standard
deviations you cannot just if they were
the same distribution you would
basically get rid of them both referred
to as X1 they are the same random
variable the scope is X1 but they're
different parametrizations of the
distribution of X1 yeah that's a very
important Point yeah of course if they
were the same gaussian would just
replace the whole thing by a gaussian by
that one gaussian yeah
is it important is it just an example oh
this is just because machine Learners
like to see this particular curve but
think of these as Boolean literals if
you like
um this is this is some this is some
some coin flip for X1 this is another
point for the price one with a different
bias it doesn't really matter it's
whatever you like it to be it's a very
simple distribution
um my question was what's proof of what
Pro property of the property division
are you going to use if any uh so the
only thing
the other thing we assume here is that
once we have a single input distribution
we can compute whatever we want to
Marginal likelihood a mode we assume
these to be tractable Atomic things okay
so here you define smoothness only for a
plus gauge that receives
directly inputs yes so what's the
general definition the general
definition is whatever is below here it
has a scope it's a set of random
variables that is being represented by
that distribution the Scopes have to be
the same even if there's multiple
variables in the scope the same set
before the same the same variable sense
yeah
yeah so in can you go back to the
previous slide
in undirected the egms it's quite common
let's say to represent a distribution
over three variables as a product of two
factors one other exponents
not decomposable because those share
variables of course the factors in
effective share variables so that's not
decomposable which means it's really not
a factorization of independent things
you're actually multiplying conditional
probabilities or yeah so so that's not
what we're talking about here
I see and that's also an intractable
model for that exactly that reason
yeah
so what I will tell you after the break
is with these two simple properties
which are totally intuitive I hope you
can compute tractable marginals on
whatever circuit you like however big it
is in time linear in the number of edges
so hopefully you'll come back for that
afternoon if you leave any of these
conditions then you can stick out well
smoothness you can always get back with
a simple operation decomposability is
necessary
yeah okay intern we'll talk about this
kind of is it a necessary condition
problem uh
all right thank you okay let's thank you
let's take a couple of minutes for
questions if there are any questions
yes
because people study the holy languages
over this priorities as well
this is what will hopefully do the next
two hours is to tell you how to compute
entropy scale divergences marginal
mapping currency
causal effects
yeah you don't think of the discovery
language
what do you think of as a query language
something that allows you to Define
these queries
yeah so we'll talk a little bit about an
actual query language which is how do we
compose
products logs integrals like there will
be a little language Illusions part
um
but yeah let's think of an interesting
language to Define
in fact actually the causality work
which is actually benches is also about
you're given a graph which is your
causal assumptions which you can think
of as the query language and now can I
compute effects on my distribution so
there are later the queries will become
more structured and they will start to
look more like an actual language rather
than just values for variables
absolutely please so can you explain
again what the dependencies say stop
show up what why can't you just take all
the part of the network which is labeled
by the X1
that gives you x one yeah
a simple example is uh okay let's come
up with some really dumb example of the
spot
um let's say that my location is
Berkeley then it's very likely that
I don't know the weather is nice and
there are smart people around us okay so
and let's say that these are independent
variables okay if I'm in uh
I don't know I shouldn't have said smart
people
let's say the weather the weather is
nice and some other level they're
independent but they're very likely to
be true inverted okay let's say now I'm
in Belgium I have two other animals I
have the same random database and
um they're also independent of each
other but they're likely to be not the
case now
if you don't know where you are and I
tell you the first variable is set to
true you're more likely to be in
Berkeley which means the second variable
is also more likely to be true even
though in Berkeley they're independent
in Belgium they're independent in the
mixture they depend on each other does
that make sense
in the circuit I mean what a circuits
so try to
get independent parts for X1 and X2 and
then everything seems to be independent
so yes you could somehow turn this into
you'll get another marginal distribution
over X2 but you can do this for any
distribution I can always take a
distribution where things depend on each
other and get two marginal distributions
but why isn't that distribution that you
are getting because the the for the kind
of Berkeley Belgium Belgian example the
mixture actually makes things depends on
each other if I if I know that in one of
these
mixture components some something is
more likely everything becomes more
likely that mixture come closer so what
is the definition of what is the exact
definition of plus plus
okay it's
it's exactly this it's just a classic
mixture model
we compute the probability in both
components and we average
yeah
it's the same random particle so they're
both labeled X1 oh yeah if I have
multiple random rows this just becomes a
vector of random variables
variables may I suggest that we continue
this during the break because people are
looking for copy okay so let's say he
wants once more
[Applause]